I think plants present an opportunity
for people to look closely at something
and get invested in something that's
truly very much outside of themselves
plants are not like us and the more you
study plants the more different and deep
ways you see that they are not like us
all the important things that we do from
how we move around to how we reproduce
to how we react to the Sun any human
activity you could point to you're gonna
see something very different in plants
and the more you know about how plants
function and the more you watch them
function and test their functioning the
more deeply you understand how different
they are
I think that's useful because I think
people have a need to transcend
themselves and I know that when I get
bogged down in the dysfunctionality z--
of how people treat each other and
conflicts between men and women and
money problems and science and all this
kind of thing that I can take some
comfort and joy in transcending what
seemed like very small-scale human noise
and look at the differences in a life
form that's been successfully occupying
the planet for four hundred million
years so quite frankly I get a lot of
joy and comfort and happiness from
considering these things I mean I think
that's the main reason to do science is
that it feeds the soul I think that and
I see this in students year after year
that the more you know about the world
the more you feel like you're part
and it's it's like nothing else
you know you teach somebody not to just
walk by a tree but to look up at it and
say yep that one's deciduous and that
one's evergreen and that one is gonna
lose its leaves this fall but that one's
going to stay green just very basic
things like that and you see people
sense of self and self esteem rise and
all of a sudden they know something
about the world that they journey
through and it makes them a little bit
bigger as a person and that's really a
wonderful thing to watch in students and
to be able to facilitate so I think we
should plant trees not to save trees I
think planning a tree is not unlikely to
be a method you use to save yourself and
to find a meaning in something that will
be with you and grow with you and be
something you can come back to and
contrast your own life with I'm very
influenced by some research that came
out I think in the 80s that compared
retention during learning and I remember
very strongly that the main result of
that was the the larger the number of
senses that you invoked if you were
touching something if you were writing
and listening and watching and even
smelling something or tasty you know the
more senses that you could engage during
learning the more effectively that
information was integrated into the
person and learned I think with digital
media were very very strongly going
towards a medium that is visual only I
mean you do hear the message etc but I
worry that it's a
massive stance just in terms of using
the five senses and that you can't learn
passively I think the best learning is
done with active manipulation and we
need to be able to work with our hands
you know it's not just about using our
brains I mean eventually we have to
manipulate the world with our hands in
order to make tangible change right and
students need practice with that kids
need practice with that we need to do
that in life and for better or worse you
know our screen experiences will never
never give us that it's very important
to put children in a environment where
they can take things apart where they
can break things and then learn to fix
them where they can trust their hands
and know their capacity to manipulate
objects and I see that as a much more
active interaction than what the newer
types of technology offer as they supply
learning so you know I'm not anti screen
etc but I do worry that the hours we
spend that way are replacing some of the
things that are going to be important
you